ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
นักเรียนทุกคนใส่แล้วก็กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2
คนหนอในชั่วโมงดินเนอร์ในวีดีโอ
บีกินเนอร์
วีดีโอ Wiki หน้าเอ้อใช่แล้วค่ะ
ผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะครูฟ้าราคะ
วันนี้สบายดีไหม
วันนี้สบายดีค่ะแข็งแรงๆพี่ชายดีมากค่ะ
E5 มากมากินข้าวแล้วใช่ไหมคะกินแล้วอิ่ม
แล้วกู
หนังโป๊มีที่พักกินข้าวแล้วเหมือนกันค่ะ
ค่ะกินขนมปัง Ham  Cheese  Sandwich เนาะ
กิน sanu ไป
2 ชิ้น
อิ่มไส้ไหมคะ
อิ่มมากนอน
แซนวิชเนี่ยครูฟ้าทำเองไหมคะทำเองค่ะทำอี
โง่มีขนมปังใช่ไหมขนมปัง
ขนมปังแบบนี้
เลยจะมีชีสนกเป็นชีสรา
ชีสเยิ้มใช่มั้ยแล้วก็มีแฮม
อ้าวหรอแล้ว
ขอฟังมาปิดทับ Bag ขนมปังแล้วก็เป็นขนม
ปังแฮมชีส
คะคุณ 2
พูด Shop
ครูฟังทำอาหารได้สิใช่ไหมคะทำอาหารได้ค่ะ
ครูหญิงถ้าครูมาทำอาหารได้อยู่เนี่ยแล้ว
ครูฟ้าคิดใช่ไหมคิด
อยากเป็นแม่ครัวไหมทำอาหาร
ดีค่ะอยากเป็นแม่ครัวรั้วกิน
เค้กใช่มั้ยชอบคุกกี้ชอบมาดูรองอ๋อเหรอ
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยโอ้ก็เลยอยากเป็นแม่ครัว
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าเป็นผู้หญิงก็เป็นแม่ครัว
[เพลง]
ครัวจะเป็นใช่ไหม
ถ้าอาชีพนี้ล่ะคะสิ่งที่เราเป็นอยู่
ครูตอนเด็กๆครูฟ้าคิดอยากเป็นครูไหม
ตอนเด็กๆอายุ
อายุน้อย
4-15
อายุ
ตอนแต่กูเด็ก
กูฟามไม่อยากเป็นครูคะค่ะทำไมทำไมครูบา
ไม่อยากเป็นครู
ไม่ชอบ
ยูนิฟอร์มขอ
เสื้อ
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะไม่ชอบค่ะ
เป็นครูว่าคุณครูต้องใส่เสื้อใส่กับลุง
ที่เป็นชุดยูนิฟอร์มครู
นายมีคนค่ะ
รองเท้า
รองเท้าเห็นหนึ่งไม่ชอบอยู่ในฟอร์มก็เลย
ไม่เป็นครูผู้หญิงจากเป็นครูไหมกูรู้คุย
อีกเนี่ยตั้งแต่เด็กๆเนี่ยอยากเป็นครูมาก
ๆทำให้ยาก
สอน
ชอบพูดหรอยถ้าชอบพูดพูดชอบสอนก็เลยคิดก็
โตขึ้นอยากเป็นครูหรือ
อยากเป็นครูตั้งแต่อย่างนี้
ตอนนี้ก็เป็นครูครูผู้หญิงเนี่ยอยากเป็น
ครูแล้วได้เป็นครูครู
ไม่อยากเป็นครูแต่ได้เป็นครูแตะถ้าไม่มี
ยูนิฟอร์ม
ไม่ต้องใส่อยู่ในโต
อาชีพต่อไป
คุณหมอสมัยคุณหมอเวลาเราไม่สบายเราก็ไป
โรงพยาบาลหาคุณหมอครูฟ้าอยากเป็นหมอไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าน่าไม่อยากเป็นหมออ๋อค่ะอ่ะรู้มั้ย
ทำไมครูฟ้าไม่อยากเป็นหมอหน้ากูฟ้าโอเคนะ
เป็นหมอเนี่ยจริงๆน่านักน่า
แต่ไอคิวทีได้นะ
ไอ้ชิบ
เพราะว่าหมอใช่ไหมคุณหมอในประเทศไทยเนี่ย
ต้องเรียนหนังสือเก่งมากๆ
เลยต้องไอคิวดีต้องฉลาดภาษาไทยก็ไม่ต้อง
ฉลาดเรียนเก่งมาต้องเก่งเคมีใบโลจี้ไปหา
แมกเนติก fit4u
ฟิสิกส์อะไรบ้างไม่ต้องหรอแล้วก็ต้อง
เรียนค่ะเออใช่มั้ยอ่านๆแต่กูฟ้าไม่อยาก
เป็นหมอเพราะว่ากูฮักกลัวฤดูอะไร
เต็มกูมีรูปก็ได้มั้ยได้ค่ะได้ไม่ได้ไม่
กลัวขนาดนั้นนี่เลือดซึ่งเอ๊ยเลือดอย่าง
เงี้ยเพื่อ
ให้เพราะเป็นหมอเนี่ยต้องอย่างนี้ใช่ไหม
หนังหรือว่าเลือดทั้งเรียนกลัวไหมอ่า
ใช่ไหมคะคุณฟ้ากลัวเลือดไอเคยไม่อยากเป็น
หมอไม่อยากเป็นหมอคุณหมอต้องข่าที่เห็น
เลือดทุกวันต้องเห็นหัวใจใช่มั้ยหัวใจ
กลัวกลัว
นะเออ
ลูกผู้หญิงโอเคไหมเป็นหมอเป็นหมออีกหรอคะ
ไม่เอา
เหมือนฉันบอกเหมือนครูฟ้าน่าไม่ชอบรวย
ด้วยเธอไม่ชอบเห็ดเลือดเห็นหัวใจ
น่า
[เพลง]
กลัวเหมือนครูฟ้าไม่คืนไม่อยากเป็นกับ
อาชีพต่อไป
ครูฟ้าประเทศไทยเป็นได้หรอฟ้าอยากเป็นนัก
บินอวกาศไหมคะ
อยากเป็นค่ะ
มายอยากเป็นนักบินอวกาศค่ะ
ไม้สิอยากไปออกอยากไปนาซ่าอยากเห็นว่าดาว
เนปจูน You  Are  Not
ด่วนจันทร์เนี้ยหรอดวงจันทร์หนึ่งใช่ไหม
คะ
ดวงจะ
หรือว่าดวงอาทิตย์
[เพลง]
อยากเห็นดวงจันทร์ใช่ไหม
หรือเพื่อทีก็จะไม่เป็นไรเอ่อเออ
เออดูทิศไม่ได้อยากแต่จะเห็นข้างนอกไงแต่
ประเทศไทยไม่มีเนาะก็เป็นไม่ได้เป็นไม่
ได้ใช่ต้องไปเอานาฬิกาใช่มั้ยน้องอเมริกา
มีนาซ่า NASA ก็จะมีนักบินอวกาศ
ให้ฉันอ่ะอาชีพต่อไปไม่รู้กรูฟ้าอยากเป็น
หรือเปล่าแต่ผู้หญิงคิดว่าอยากเป็น
อะไรอ่ะกูฟ้าอยากเป็นช่างภาพไหมคะ
ช่างภาพมันก็คือก็ุถ่ายรูปใช่ไหม
แล้วก็ถ่ายรูปครูฟ้าอยากเป็นไหมช่างภาพ
ผู้คะอยากเป็นช่างภาพค่ะนอกหรือว่าตา
กล้องมั้ยคนไทยเลขช่างภาพตากล้อง
มีอะไรกล้องใช่ได้ช่างถ่ายรูปช่าง 5 ภาพ
การแข่งทำไมอ่ะทำไมครูฟ้าอยากเป็นช่างภาพ
พระภูมิฟ้าเรียนตอนอยู่อยู่ดูที่นี่จะพา
University อูฟาเรียนถ่ายรูปเปลี่ยนง
อื่นๆรูปก็เลยคิดว่าเป็นช่างถ่ายรูปก็
โอเคชอบถ่ายรูปวิวถ่ายรูปแมวไหม
ฉันถ่ายรูปแนวถ่ายรูปหมา
หนูเออชอบหนึ่งก็เลยอยากเป็นเนาะอยากเป็น
ผู้ใหญ่ได้หรอ
ต่อไปค่ะ
ครูประวิทย์ถูกว่าครูฟ้าอยากเป็นช่างถ่าย
รูปมืออาชีพต่อไปครูฟ้าก็อยากเป็น
ตำรวจไหมคะ
ตำรวจกวดครูฟ้าไม่อยากเป็นตำรวจค่ะเอ้า
ทำไมทำไมไม่อยากเป็นตำรวจ
ตำรวจเนี่ยต้องมวยไทยใช่มั้ยใครบอก
ต้องถือปืนมีคนไม่ดี
ต้องสู้
ฉันชอบไม่ชอบ
หือตำรวจค่ะ
เป็นอันนี้แล้วกันกูป่ะเป็นตำรวจจราจร
โอเคไหม
ไม่ต้องไม่ต้องตกๆสู้ไม่ต้องยืนแล้วปิด
ปิดโอเคมั้ย
มาช่วยจราจร
ไม่อยากเป็นตำรวจจราจรค่ะ
ออกซิเจนไม่โอเค
ว่ามีรถใช่ไหมค่ะมีรถแล้วก็
ตำรวจ
คิดว่าหายใจไม่โอเคก็เลย
ก็เลยไม่อยากเป็นตำรวจจราจร
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยากเป็นนักบินอวกาศใช่ไหมคะ
แต่ว่าประเทศไทยอ่ะไม่มีแต่อันนี้ประเทศ
ไทยมีแล้วก็คล้ายๆกัน
ครูฟ้าอยากเป็นนักบินไหม
อ้าวนักบินขับเครื่องบิน
ไม่อยากเป็นค่ะเอ้าทำไมอ่ะ
กูฟ้าการขับเครื่องบินไม่เก่ง
เหอะ
ขับรถก็ไม่โอเคขับรถไม่โอเคใช่มั้ยขับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไม่โอเค
คิดว่าขับเครื่องบินคนคนคนอะไรล่ะงูแต่
ว่า
ครูฟ้าไม่อยากเป็นคนขับเครื่องบินแต่อย่า
ทำงานบนเครื่องบินไหม
ทำงานบนเครื่องบินสมัยเครื่องบินถ้าครู
ฟ้าไม่อยากเป็นนักบินขับเครื่องบินคุณฟ้า
ก็เป็น
แอร์โฮสเตสไงจะไปเล็กๆนะ
อยากเป็นแอร์โฮสเตส 5 โห
เเอร์โฮสเตสก็ทำงานบนตั้งเครื่องบิน
เหมือนนักบินใช่ไหม
ทำไมอ่ะทำไมครูฟ้าอยากเป็นแอร์โฮสเตส
เพราะแอร์โฮสเตสเนี่ยได้ไปประเทศอเมริกา a
เฮ้ยให้ไปประเทศอิตาลี
ไปฝรั่งเศสไปญี่ปุ่นไปสวิตเซอร์แลนด์ใน
ชื่อแจนไหมอ่า
หน้ากากเป็นนักดนตรีค่ะในรูปนี้เนี่ยผู้
ชายเนี่ยเขาเป่าอะไรเนี่ยแป้งโฟนไมค์ Jack
Phone ทำไมเป็นเครื่องดนตรีมาเป็นนัก
ดนตรีแซกโซโฟนครูฟ้าล่ะจะเล่นดนตรีอะไร
เปลี่ยนโอ
ไวโอลีน
ครูฟ้าจะเล่นกีตาร์ค่ะเดี๋ยวพลอย
กีต้าร์เห็น
มือคู่ฟ้าโอเค
เล่นกี่ต้าหาย
ว่ากูพาชอบเล่นกีต้าร์
เราก็ชอบหรอกตัวเองก็เลยไม่อยากนักดนตรี
แล้วอยากเป็นนักร้องด้วยไหม
ยากเป็นนักร้องค่า
ครูสาวบอกว่าครูฝ่ายชอบร้องเพลงก็อาจจะ
อยากมีนักร้อง
ไห้
เลยชอบแล้วอยากเป็นนักเต้นด้วยไหมค่ะ
อยากเป็นนักเต้นหาเป็นไม่เคยได้สันเธอ
เป็นนักเต้นแบบเต้นน้องเต้นเต้นเต้นเออ
แต่ง
เต้น
สุดท้าย
ไฟฟ้าชอบดนตรีชอบร้องเพลงชอบเต้น
ไทยค่ะ
อยากในเลนส์อยากเป็นแว็กซ์ได้ทั้งหมดที่
ครูหญิงถามครูฟ้าครูฟ้าอยากเป็นอะไรมาก
ที่สุด
อยากเป็น
นักร้องค่ะขอดูฟ้าอยากเป็นนักร้องเนาะนี่
นี่นักร้องมากที่สุดถ้าใช้ Talk มากเอา
ไว้อยู่บ้านใช่มั้ยเวลากูฟ้าอาบน้ำขอร้อง
เพลงไปด้วย
กับนักเต้นนะนักร้องกับนั้นก็คือยังฟ้า
อยากร้องเพลงแล้วก็ในเพลงเนี่ยก็มีท่า
เต้นใช่ไหมอ่านแต่อยากไปด้วยอยากเป็นครู
สอนเต้นขอ
วุฒิครูหญิงเนี่ยบอกว่าเออสวัสดีค่ะค่ะ
อยากเรียนเต้นที่
ได้เลยค่ะฟ้านะคะ Dancing  through นะคะ
ทำยังไงคะถ้าจะเรียนเต้นต้อง step1  2  3
Step  1 ต้องเอ็กไซด์ก่อนใช้ทรายอ่ะ
ตั้งแต่สเต็ปหนึ่งแล้ว
ครูสอนเต๊กครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็เด็กๆสมัยครูฟ้า
บอกว่าครูฟ้าไม่ไม่อยากเป็นครูก็สวยเพราะ
ว่าเวลาเราคิดถึงครูก็ต้องมีชุดยูนิฟอร์ม
แต่ถ้ามีเด็กๆอยากเรียนเต้นแล้วครูฟ้าสอน
เต้นอยากเรียนร้องเพลง
ครู Fah สอนร้องเพลงเป็นครูเหมือนกัน
ได้ให้เป็นโครงการแต่ไม่ใช่ครูแบบที่ครู
ฟ้าแล้วก็คือหญิงคิดสวยไปลาเราเห็นตอน
เด็กๆ
ก็จะ
โดเรมี่
ชอบ
คือสอนเต้นจ่ายนะก็ครูฟ้าอยากเป็นใช่ไหม
เราก็อยากรู้ว่าเอ่อนักเรียนตอนเด็กๆจาก
เป็นอะไรเป็นอะไรแล้วก็ทำใหม่จะไม่ทำไม
อยากเป็นๆก็
ก็ได้นะคะอยากเป็นอะไรก็คอมเม้นบอกเราได้
ใช่ไหมคะก็มาทุกวันนี้ก็เรียนแค่นี้
เกลียดแค่นี้
นักเรียนก็อย่าลืมอะไรคะคุณอย่าลืมกด like
กด Share กด Subscribe ด้วยนะคะนักเรียน
จะให้ข้าก็จะมีเลยครับเราและครูทุกๆคนนะ
วันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอ
หน้านะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ